this week we're talking about the
perfect kid benchmark er kubernetes
updates and new table formats for data
prod I'm Priyanka Vergara and welcome to
this week in cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news we've just
expanded perfect 8 benchmark err the
open source tool that makes network
performance benchmarking faster and
easier perf get benchmark ur now
supports a broader range of network
performance tests and lets you view the
results in Google Data studio the goal
is to help you predict the performance
impact of moving workloads to and across
different clouds ask google kubernetes
engine moved from version 1.1 to 2 1.15
over the past year we made several
security changes to the platform to
improve security behind the scenes
changes like paring down controls - only
what your application actually needs and
improving the defaults and of course
maintaining the GK hardening guide so
that you can always find the best advice
for the security of your clusters and
speaking of kubernetes it's never a bad
time for a kubernetes best practices
guide this one covers kubernetes
namespaces readiness probes for health
checks controlled deployment and more
because containerized app management is
a favorite of ours for deploying and
managing production apps at scale data
Prague is a fully managed service for
running Apache Hadoop ecosystem software
in the cloud and we've just added new
table format to support workloads that
need asset transactions data worsening
schema enforcement and schema evolution
check out our new guide on these formats
and let us know what you think if you
want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we will see you
in the cloud
you